you play a Jean Grey you are a I love
this role because you're a badass and
most superheroes now have to do all
these contortions and craziness too and
and cool moves and all these special
effects and everything you are able to
as an actor pretty much conserve your
energy because it's all through
telekinesis and powers that you use
through your mind yeah it's great you
know they got me a trainer started when
I first got the role they got me a
trainer and I you know I was working out
every day and then I was like what's the
point all I have to do is this I don't
have to do anything so I started eating
cheeseburgers pasta every day I really
you know I filled out the costume so it
was night because a lot of its just
literally there'll be like okay you use
your superpower and you just make a
motion with your hands yeah and then
they spend nine days having a you know a
truck go flying through the air back
eating cheeseburger and I'm over there
pasta yeah it's great drinking wine what
is what is the signature Jean Grey move
is there a signature move there's a few
but this I like the twist the doorknob
this is my twist the doorknob you just
do that also it doubles as a good dance
move yeah yeah if you do it up right
into the Queen's wave yeah yeah yeah
well it's the Queen's wave if she's
arthritic make your hand in a claw what
I'm doing
so it's this this looks creepy if you're
yeah I think you can do that don't do it
if you do it
I've been asked I was asked to get off a
subway once cuz I was there to go did
you have a good time making making the
film I had a great time making it it's
so much it's such a great cast - it's an
amazing cast I feel like I like won the
lottery or something I really shouldn't
be there how close did you all get very
very close that sounded weird the way
they said that way it sounded really
close yeah we're really good friends we
were troublemakers for sure we like to
play a lot of games like what kind of
stuff would you do to pass the time well
we play like we'd have BB gun fights and
things on set or V looks like your
actors put someone's eye out with those
things these are just like a welt yeah
that's right they also stopped because
the makeup department had to keep
covering up welts because you're firing
bb's at each other's faces yeah in
between your close-up shot yeah